six we made her go to see the exercise
that's what my family did to me and i'm
still afraid of the exorcist today i
can't spend that alone in the house we
did that with my sister in the movie
yeah we told her that it was a clown
comedy yeah
yeah yeah
and what'd she say
she hates clowns with this day oh yeah
yeah but did she like exorcist
she she likes scary movies to a point
now but she still has a thing with
clowns yeah yeah
i saw um
a movie called vhs94 i know we said it
last time yeah i've just been thinking
about it is it good
it's still good
it's a horror movie
okay sometimes will you watch doom
tonight
yeah i will what do you want me to watch
you tell me to watch something new every
time i talk to you dude do you watch
this
it hurts my feelings because when i
recommend something to you you dismiss
it
have you seen vivarium yet
i didn't you didn't know about that you
told me to watch the call and i did
you like it yeah i loved it vivarium i
will
see no i will i just said i will
you will well you know oh no no no i
like it but the thing is i like
secession can i say this i like the
session i really do i really do you
really do i love the power dynamics it's
kind of like everyone's plotting
stuff you know maybe you shouldn't have
done the red planet thing
oh yeah i messed it up it's a red planet
thing
my brother made a trick i think we
talked about it before yeah we've talked
about it we worked are we living we're
living in silver lake yeah i was super
sick one day like at the cold
and my brother i come home and my
brother goes
i saw a great movie bob
and i go
really i'm really sick right now oh you
should watch it man it'll change you
right
what's it called he goes red planet
so i'm watching red planet an hour in
and i remember being in the comp like
there's blankets
no you're yeah you're sitting like this
like this yeah yeah i remember right
yeah and i remember thinking i remember
thinking
this is the worst movie i've ever seen
out laughing so hard and i turned around
my brother i was dying it was in tears
because i tricked him he tricked me
right and he goes it sucks right and i
go you know what
i'm never going to try yeah oh that
really yeah i still think that so when
you bring up alluvium
you're right what's it called by very
vivarium vivariums it's not that great
it's jeremiah
i i i had a feeling that it was not that
great i know you'd like it though if you
like science fiction you'll like it i
love it it's like twilight zone
i've seen it yeah yeah it's okay it's
all right okay thank you and that's why
i haven't [ __ ] seen it
i and that's what don't touch him can i
can i say that in my household that the
what you
refer me to
held a high acclaim because you haven't
missed once he turned around the game of
thrones
he threw he threw cash at me
when we used to go on the road years
missed those days and he goes he goes he
goes here's 80 bucks start downloading
it from itunes tonight start watching it
bro bro he paid my old roommate 500 to
watch the whole series while you got jet
dude
i totally got your mom watched it too i
remember like she would have your old
spot i'd be in the breakdown living room
and she she's like steve did you watch
you know i'm like
yeah she would talk about it my wife
will ask so she's like does bobby have
any more recommendations for
documentaries it's the session
okay watch the session wait it's so good
okay let me i've done good things with
my money as well
a lot of good things one time i was at
the comedy store and there was a fat guy
upstairs and he was upstairs he was an
open mic
and he was
wolfing down
fried chicken